the article states is andrew tate a
dangerous role model to young men or an
internet idol for a disjointed
generation so is he dangerous or is he
an idol so basically the story that they
talk about is that he's blown up online
we all know this uh very controversial
he's uh um
was it cobra tate is that is that i've
never i've known anderson 2017. so um
a couple different things there some
some men are taking it as the gospel
shout out to the gospel and others
saying it's misogyny right so uh he
cites kings and sultans of always having
multiple women we've heard his opinion
on that we can play even a video on that
uh in one interview he said that his
father doesn't that the father doesn't
need to be around their children that
it's the mother's job to look after
their kids and that he saw his dad once
a month and when he's younger but the
point is this guy's everywhere right now
we've actually have an exchange if you
want to play that tick tock video
natalia and we'll let you guys get weigh
in on andrew tate um and everything he
talks about these days let's see this
video
audio
okay
it's a partnership yes right you and me
we're together since when you know what
i'm saying when you're when you're
trying to build a partnership and a life
with someone the end goal is you two
together
agreed so why cheat i know i understand
where you're coming from my point is
that relationships and life is full of
double standards as a whole a man's
gonna pay for everything everywhere you
go right this isn't this is a man do you
agree no i do like traditional okay so
you agree so you're traditional right so
if you want to talk about traditional
let's talk about tradition every single
man since the dawn of human time had
more than one woman every single king
every single emperor every single sultan
every single conqueror since the dawn of
human time had more than one woman all
of them every single one read a history
book read the bible it's all in there
the quran all of it you won't talk about
tradition it's all there the only reason
your mind is different the only reason
you believe differently is because the
society society's come along and told
you something but society we can change
like the world evolves things change the
world evolves yeah that's right now now
men can cut their dicks off in their
chicks all right uh rolo you know you
know tate very well so i did i did a
full video during the break i did a rift
on this let me start with ruslan because
you've never met or done okay so
thoughts on andrew tayden basically what
he's saying right now and then let rolo
respond yeah i think andrew tate is
someone that seems to be going through a
public transformation specifically with
his faith view he's atheist now all of a
sudden he's going to church he said so
he said i was an atheist now i'm going
to church twice what makes that
believable what makes that believe we
think he's trolling i think so yeah i
think he might be trolling i hope not
trolling religion yeah i hope not you
know he i mean he wouldn't be the first
one yeah in that interview he said that
so i think he's uh he's experiencing
some cognitive dissonance there i think
he's brilliant in terms of how he's been
able to leverage the internet i can't
tell how much of this is hyperbole can't
tell how much of this is a character
i've seen videos of him breaking
character and like laughing at himself
and so i think from from a marketing
standpoint i think it's very sharp i
think when you're going to those types
of languages like what what do we what
are we again what is the average person
going to think i'm entitled to multiple
women can an average person take care of
multiple women can an average person
have multiple kids with multiple women
you know the statistics on how
devastating it is to a man to have
multiple kids with multiple women one
thing i'll say and then i would get
you know what percentage of the world is
on andrew tate's level and i i i respect
what he's doing
good looking you're talking about money
muscles in game the guy's a four-time
kickboxing championship okay so guys
making millions a month like the the
problem is and and i i respect what he's
doing
99.999 percent of you will never be on
andrew tate's level or on a level near
andrew none of you guys are gonna be
lebron now you're gonna be michael
jordan none of you guys are gonna be
brady i'm not saying that that's who he
is but the guy's a [ __ ] g
and if he if he's one of the few that
can multiple spin plates as rolo says
more power to your brother but what is
that what is the logical conclusion of
that he becomes nick cannon he becomes
the guy with 10 11 baby mamas and he
feels bad about not being able to spend
time with his kids how many kids do you
think he has right now i don't know how
many kids he has i don't care zero okay
well i mean how many how many uh
abortions have been a part of that right
good question i mean statistically
speaking that you're you're you're yeah
so now you'll never know so now again
we're we're contributing to the very
type of society that we don't want to
see happen we're contributing to these
things we're contributing to promiscuity
we're contributing to high body counts
we're contributing to abortion yet we
say we're against all those things
there's a lot of cognitive dissonance
there so i think yeah the logical
conclusion of an android tape is he's
nick cannon and that may sound sexy
until you're nick cannon and then you
feel like an
let's be honest this is that philosophy
fleshed out let's make notes
be very clear
and choose wisely dangerous role model
or internet idol
uh both he's clearly both okay
so not one or the other i think one i
think i think uh i think some of his
rhetoric is dangerous some of his stuff
is common sense right and i think that
clip right there uh i think is is
problematic put up a poll dangerous role
model we know where this is gonna skew
night out
okay uh do you wanna give the answer
that question dangerous um okay a role
model or an internet idol
internet idol right now but is the is
that positive or is that negative
because right now i've got high school
hell i was just at the deli ed the
centric and i had some kid talk to me
about hey mr rolo do you know andrew
tate and i like i've got a 17 year old
guy who tells me as all of his high
school friends
watch tate and they know that i've been
on fresh and fit with tate and they know
there's a connection between the two of
us so they're not asking me about me
they're asking me about tate right so is
he a role model he for better or worse
he is he's put himself in i keep telling
i said this on jeddah dies show as well
it's like today
men get their education not in schools
because we tell them to stay away from
universities and we tell them to stay
away from you know a modern education
whatever they don't see any point in
going to high school but you know where
they get their education from they get
it from youtube they get it from online
sources they get it from you know chat
rooms or whatever it is and so
for better or worse andrew tate is is a
teacher just like i'm a teacher just
like you we're all teachers in this room
right now because people are going to
look at this and they're going to go
okay well here's here's what's being
taught in this particular class in fact
i tried in my own my own show i try to
emphasize that like here classes in
session get your notebooks out guys so
when when i see something like this as
again i think he's a brilliant marketer
he uh he owned he successfully owns the
the algorithm for youtube uh through
instagram through twitter everything
else i don't think enough people know
like what he's really about is it a
character is it not that's part of his
his mystique that's part of his uh his
appeal is the fact that like people
don't know that and does he break
character occasionally yeah maybe maybe
he does um it just depends on like where
you know what what
what he's getting into so if you like
that clip click right here to watch
another or if you want to watch the
entire sauz cast click right here
[Music]